US Supreme Court justices are tonight
considering a major case that could
affect union workers nationwide Fox News
at night anchor shannon bream has
specifics the fundamental issue is my
right to choice Illinois public employee
mark Janice says from the time a union
fee was deducted from his first paycheck
he's never had the right to say either
yes or no to having the Union represent
him and while he says he's not against
unions he is opposed to being forced to
underwrite their political speech during
arguments at the Supreme Court Monday
Justice Kennedy put it this way quote
what we're talking about here is
compelled justification and compelled
subsidization of a private party a
private party that expresses political
views constantly for decades the High
Court has debated how best to handle
Union fees for workers who do benefit
from the organization's collective
bargaining efforts but who do not want
to lend any support to their political
activities justice Sotomayor suggested
today that it's sometimes part of the
bargain quote we've compelled people to
pay Bar Association's bar members can
come out any day they want and say they
don't take the same position on a policy
question as the Bar Association any
union members free to get up publicly in
any setting he or she wants to say they
don't agree with the position the union
is taking
as for the potential impact on millions
of unionized government employees both
sides admitted membership would likely
drop if the Union loses this case with
Chief Justice John Roberts noting unions
would likely have to work harder to make
their case to employees it's a heated
issue now pitting the state's Governor
and Attorney General on opposite sides
when a government union boss can give
campaign cash to get a politician
elected and then sit across the table
from them after they're elected and
negotiate terms that's that's a conflict
it's effective bribe this case is not
about impinging on anybody's First
Amendment rights the law already
protects people's First Amendment rights
this is a case where there are a small
group of very well-funded right-wing
extremists that want to eliminate unions
throughout this country eight of the
nine justices have voted on similar
cases within recent years we know how
they voted splitting evenly four to four
so there's an enormous focus on the
newest member on the bench justice Neel
Gorsuch normally very chatty and engaged
in the arguments Brett today he did not
say a word so you're gonna have to wait
until their ruling it's due by June
quickly Mike mentioned the daca
situation basically they just want this
thing to be ironed out in the lower
courts to come forward yet there was no
ruling on the merits today it's not as
if the Supreme Court ruled one way or
the other about whether the program is
good or not legal or not they're saying
they want some of this lower court stuff
to play out before they get involved all
right Jenna as always thank you see you
at 11:00 p.m. Eastern